from screen junkie studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy
signor good morning good morning or good
afternoon I should say hi everyone I'm
Alicia Malone filling in for Andy signor
who is with the force at Star Wars
celebration so I've taken over once
again for another episode of classic
film fights as always we Define classic
here as pre
1980 and we have some really really
tough questions like who is the greatest
director working in the 70s how are we
going to argue that or which classic
film star do you want to see in a
violent gritty R-rated movie now you can
join in on the fun live on Twitter using
the hash movie fights live but you ain't
seen nothing yet cuz it's time to meet
our Fighters and we haven't only rounded
up The Usual Suspects because making his
movie fights debut you've seen seen him
on the Today's Show you've seen him on
Access Hollywood you've seen him on
Turner Classic Movies Dave ker hi thanks
so much for having me I'm going to do my
very best to try to keep up with these
guys I can't wait it's going to be fun
and uh he has left the gun but he's
taken the canoli the host of screen
junkies show looking very Dapper how
radnik hey you know uh when you when you
when you do a hit you got to have some
dessert um and uh I enjoy you're singing
up top I thought the Andrew sisters were
in the house for a moment stop it and
where he's going he doesn't need any
roads because he's the movie fights
Champion Mr Dan Marl I don't know who
the Andrew sisters
are I I will trust how on that reference
so much fun I'm so happy to do classic
film fights I love Classic Movies it's
great to be able to do a different thing
than just yell about sequest or you know
Darth Vader in the show yeah it's fun I
like it well they say that a boy's best
friend is his mother but a judge's best
friend on movie fights is the fact
Checker Mr Lon Harris hi hey how's it
going I'm just here to check facts and
chew bubblegum Y and you're all I'm all
out of gum hey that's my
Liney and making his debut on the fan
cam all the way from Down Under that's
not a knife it's Adam Horton hello how
you doing good thank you it's good to uh
yeah good to be here it's pretty crazy
to see it all so yeah happy to be here
see it all happen right in front of your
eyes the magic well as you guys know
it's not about my personal choice when
it comes to picking these winners it's
about your argument and with classic
films there is no right or wrong answer
really so I see this as a celebration of
Classics I can't wait to hear everything
that you've got to say and uh let's have
some fun and a little bit of the old
Ultraviolence it's round
one hit it JT
well round one the first question is oh
I want to fight you you want to fight
let
him St this colorize this is
colorization all right now it's time for
round one what is the greatest alltime
fem fatal performance and Dave we're
going to start with you you have a
couple of minutes to tell us about your
choice well obviously the whole Fen
fatel character is such a fascinating
role that the greatest actresses
especially in the 40s and 50s got to
play there's so many great choices but I
love this question because it allows me
to talk about one of my probably four or
five favorite classic films of all time
which is Laura Auto prevengers film from
the mid-40s and the character of Laura
is played by Jean TIY who is absolutely
one of the most beautiful women I've
ever seen seen Grace the screen she
could have turned me she's that she's
that gorgeous um but the thing that I
love about the movie is that it's so
smartly written it's so full of twists
and turns uh for people who haven't seen
it I'm not going to spoil anything but
halfway through there's this big shock
about this murder mystery that we're
learning about but what I love about the
Jean tyy performance first of all she's
gorgeous but secondly she just has such
a natural delivery and ease and Glamour
and Grace about her whereas everything
around her is in
disarray there's a murder plot there's
people are they dead are they not dead
and she's so gorgeous that every guy in
the movie is in love with her there's a
artist who's in love with her she's got
a fiance played by Vincent Price who's
obsessed with her even the police
detective who's investigating her murder
who doesn't even know her falls in love
with her and Clifton web who's
essentially gay is also in love with her
too so this woman no man can resist her
powers and I just I think she's probably
the most beautiful woman I've ever seen
on a movie screen and this is she had a
lot of Great Performances uh Black Widow
and lever to heaven where she got an
Oscar nomination but I think Laura is
her defining movie role gay character
before you can even say that they were
gay exactly uh Hal who's your choice
well um thought long and hard about it
Alicia and I'm going with uh Rita
Hayworth in lady from
Shanghai uh it's a stunning performance
for uh many reasons uh one of the things
that that I feel really sets this apart
from the others and uh makes it um the
greatest performance is how Rita
Hayworth defied expectations in this
film and it was uh a real uh about face
from what people uh were expecting from
Rita Hayworth as an actress and it was
such a shock to to the system just to
see um how she transformed her style in
playing um this uh um this
deceptive uh anenu fem fatal character
and um it's fascinating to see her
interplay with Orson Wells who she was
uh romantically involved with in real
life and um just that
electricity uh and the surprise for
America to see Rita Hayworth in this new
light um made it the single greatest uh
fem fatal performance all righty Dan I
went with my personal favorite which is
also in one of my personal favorite
movies which is uh Barbara Stanwick as
philis stricken and Double Indemnity I
love Billy Wilder he's one of my
favorite directors this is one of my
favorite screenplays for a movie all of
all time and I think part of the reason
why I love this movie so much is that
Barbara Stanwick absolutely owns this
movie and this is a movie there's no
Edward G Robinson is in this movie he's
no slouch Fred McMurray is in this movie
he's no slouch but from the second she
comes on screen wearing that anklet that
catches Fred mcmurray's eye she blows
everyone else off the screen completely
and I love especially that that for the
F fatal role which there's a lot of
reasons why this kind of archetype and
stereotype uh caught on in Europe a
little bit before it caught on in the US
which is that it threat the F fatal the
whole character of a great F fatal
threatens the power structure of society
at that time of just like the male
driven like everything runs through the
men the men are the are the people that
make the plans the men are the ones who
execute everything and what I love about
Barbara Stanwick in this movie is she
plays this role so well of this woman
who has control over everything she is
running everyone's lives in that movie
she is running that plan herself she's
got her own game going on and nobody
around her catches on and if they do
catch on she's going to destroy you and
she wields that kind of power and uses
this that sexuality in a time where you
couldn't overtly use sexuality in a
movie so well I think she is just
fantastic in that movie and I love her
and I love that movie and I love that
role she looks cool in sunglasses too
okay now it's time for counterarguments
or discussions so how D Dave Dan what do
you think about each other's choices and
why is your choice maybe a little bit
better I love both their choices and
their arguments were great I still argue
though that Jean tyny is the most
gorgeous of the three women that we
mentioned and I think for that alone and
she's never looked better than she did
in Laura I think that makes her the
ultimate Fen fatal but I love what you
said about uh Barbara Stanwick really
controlling all of all of the men in the
movie I think Jun TIY does that too
maybe not to the same degree but that's
the great thing about these fem fatals
is that they hold all the men just in
their power MH yeah I agree uh you know
Jee Tierney uh she gave great face she's
uh one of the loveliest uh you know uh
women in Hollywood history but um I
would contend that uh both great
actresses but that type of bravado um in
these fem fatal roles or that kind of um
cold uh detached attitude that Jee
Tierney brought to so many of her roles
it's consistent throughout their careers
whereas this is a singular performance
unexpected and that much more of a shock
to the system if you went to a Barbara
Stanwick film and uh saw Barbara
Stanwick as a type A personality that
was what she does that was that's what
she does in every movie she's in more or
less to some degree and Jee tyy uh um
yes uh she's uh cold and deceptive she
like uh cornered the market on that but
this Rita Hayworth role is so singularly
unexpected and the Intrigue that she
brings and the classic scenes that she
uh that that uh
she uh really manipulates throughout the
film like that Hall of Mirrors scene um
opposite Orson Wells uh she is um yeah I
think without parallel but I think Rita
Hayworth was a transformational figure
not just in that movie I mean Gilda and
and so many other movies like that was
kind of what she did is she took on
roles that kind of defied the Norms of
the time and I think that her she was
kind of a varied actress and I think
that that's kind of what she was also
known for I think they're all kind of in
their own way playing to their types I
think what we're really talking about is
their performance in these F fatal roles
and what I think puts Stanwick above the
other two is I agree that Jee tyy and
Laura is very is desired very much so by
everyone in that movie but I think that
she's kind of secondary to the overall
plot of the movie as far as like
everyone's kind of planning around her
but she herself doesn't I don't think
play that pivotal of a role in the
execution of everything I think in lady
from Shanghai Rita Hayworth again she's
a little more integral in the planning
of everything but she's in cahoots with
other characters she's in cahoots with
different you know she's working with
that one she's working with that one why
I think Barbara stck owns this so well
is that she doesn't need that her
performance alone she owns that entire
plot she owns everything that happens in
that story and she doesn't have to rely
on oh I have to work with this person to
get it done she works with Fred McMurray
but that's because she manipulates him
she doesn't you know he doesn't come to
her with the plan and say I'm gonna work
with you to do this she manipulates him
into doing it thinking all the time he
thinks that he's working with her but
he's not he's working for her he's never
doing anything but working for her and
the way to kind of portray that it's
almost like a double a double
performance because she has to like act
for Fred McMurray and the same time
she's acting in the film and I think
there's a real Duality I think there's a
lot of layers to her character that
maybe aren't as present in the other two
I think that it's a much more nuanced
performance in that the character of
Phyllis dieten has to keep up so many
faces and so many different fronts and I
think that Stanwick does that so well in
that movie I would uh contend that uh
Rita Hayworth's character is also more
unique in the scheme of things because
uh the Dame and the pi kind of setup
that uh Barbara Stanwick was involved in
it kind of has become a cliche and again
that is towards the top of the Heap of
that
um Dynamic but um nonetheless the uh
Rita Hayworth I feel is it's a much more
unique and challenging uh role in film
as well L from Shanghai all right Dave
final thoughts last chance to I mean
here the I I probably shouldn't say this
but I'm kind of swayed by and barber
Stan was was my second choice but that
was pretty darn good it's hard for me to
argue with that um I still love my Gene
tyrany and I just love that movie Laura
but I I mean both of you guys make great
arguments all right sing Lon any facts
or anything to add uh not really a lot
of facts to check everybody kept it
pretty fact
a lot of people on Twitter a lot of love
for Mary Aster and mtis Falcon and
Lauren ball into have and have not came
up a few times also lots of love from
everybody on Twitter for everyone
dressing up calls this the classiest
classic movie fights to dat I know I
didn't think I'd get these boys dressed
up but they look great oh cheers right
back at you you're a real you're a real
tomato if I may say so myself real Dizzy
Dame um such great arguments I mean
you've got the beauty the surprise the
control all elements that make up a
great fem fatal performance um I like
what each of you had to say about your
choice but in terms of talking about the
uh the performance itself and how she
didn't need anyone else I'm going to say
that Dan you are the stuff that dreams
are made of and you get the
point Twitter Twitter agrees I have your
poll results oh yes I forget about that
45% for Double Indemnity 36% for Rita
Hayworth and lady from shangai 19% Jee
Tierney and Lura but I think part of
that might be that more of our viewers
need to see Laura all of these films so
good I'd love to give quick shout out to
uh one of the great modern femes Linda
fantino in the
9s oh my goodness I love that film Noah
came back in the '90s in that form and
it's always about uh suspicion over the
ladies you got to watch out for us we
don't have too much power all right
round two is who is the best director of
the' 70s we are going to do this one as
a blind fight because what in the world
what kind what kind of a [__] and Bull
story is going on here and by the way
that's very mean to do to someone who's
never been on the show to say that for
the record yeah throwing my friend Dave
through a
loop well the thing is you each chose
Francis bopa so we thought he true he
the best director oh I shouldn't say
that so the question should have been
who's the second best
director yeah we've put him in as well
as your second choices and some other
great directors from the 70s each going
to pick your choice and then you argue
uh Dave pick yours first we am I looking
at it or just picking it oh my gosh we
we'll reveal who it is crazy huh
whoever all right see it's going to be
interesting being a so many ways this
could go I know they're all really good
so it's Just
sh reveal your choices Dave what's your
man okay well my the one that I picked
is Steven Spielberg Spielberg how what
do you have Martin scorsi scori Dan I
have Woody Allen oh Woody Allen nice
okay how your chance first tell us about
scori uh well Martin scori is absolutely
the best director of the 70s and um it's
uh for uh several reasons one um he made
his best film taxi driver in the 70s um
two uh he created and uh defined a genre
uh the crime film with mean streets um
that uh gritty neighborhood street tough
uh genre that's been borrowed from uh so
often so he created a genre he's uh one
of the great living directors who made
his uh greatest film created um the most
some of the most layered characters uh
We've uh ever seen he created one of the
greatest Partnerships Dynamics in Motion
Picture history starting his work with
Robert dairo and um he jumped uh to
different genres and textures with uh I
mean making a personal story about a
strong single mother with Alice doesn't
live here anymore um he showed such uh
an A A Deft hand with such varied
material um in a great decade he is the
best director you're talking to
me what I'm the only one here you must
be talking to me Dan yes Woody Allen
Woody Allen uh Woody Allen is I
think first of all I mean just in
general it's I cannot believe how
prolific the guy is and continues to be
but when you look at the 70s
specifically I think one of the hardest
things to
do and stay relevant is comedy comedy is
so subjective to its time and so easy to
fall out of date there's so many classic
comedies that from their times that that
don't hold up and Woody Allen made three
or four of them in the 70s uh sleeper is
as funny today as it was when it was
released everything you want to know
about sex but we're afraid to ask is is
as funny today as it was when it was
released you add to that Annie Hall
which is the Best Picture Winner which
is uh comedy and drama uh in equal
measure both uh so deafly um executed
you have Manhattan which is a great film
that he closed out the decade with uh
again something that people weren't
expecting from him and that he was you
know so known for what he did
comedically Manhattan came out and it
wasn't that it was a different shade of
him and it showed that he had more to do
than just be the kind of goofy oneliner
which he started out as a standup
comedian and I think that when you just
look at the fact that he was able to to
definitely kind of move between these
different takes on things and it's kind
of like you know with Ginger Rogers and
Fred stair you know Ginger Rogers did
the same thing but backwards and in
heels like Woody Allen directed but also
acted and also uh wrote so he he did
everything that a director has to do
plus in most of them the leading man
part plus writing them and I think that
just the ability to do that so so well
uh really it's unparalleled as far as
like just the range of skill needed and
the amount of in output and the quality
of it back with sending heels a book by
Alicia malan out in August I didn't even
know
segue yeah Dave tell us about Steven
Spiel well let's first say that if this
question was who was the best director
of the 80s we wouldn't even have a
discussion because of course it would be
Steven Spielberg who started off the 80s
with Raiders of the Lost Arc and but
actually he's also the best director of
the 70s why because of all the people
we're talking about who has created the
most iconic lasting movies that have
stood the test of time to today from
that decade it's Spielberg he had you
know his kind of cult films like duel in
the early '70s but then it was was the
onew punch of Jaws and Close Encounters
of the Third Kind in the middle of the
decade that were humongous hits back
then instant Classics but have really
stood the test of time unlike any other
movie that we're talking about right now
and was were massive hits for critics
and audiences alike unlike any other
movie we're talking about on this panel
so and then he ended the decade with
1941 which was a very different film a
funnier film a lighter film so I think
he showed at a much younger age than
Woody Allen and scorsi too it should be
mentioned that he was off to an amazing
start in the 70s awesome old pot of new
Hollywood all great but uh let's open
the floor so I'm about to commit heresy
as a
Jew but um yeah Spielberg is not the
best director of the 70s uh 1941 was a
complete misfire he had to recover from
that and um this is uh I'm going to
throw out a controversial statement I
don't think Close Encounters holds up
well what oh yeah because oh um I think
it drags I think it's um I think it's uh
very slow I think just uh pacing wise he
uh I mean it's uh it's got some uh like
marvelous uh motifs and things to look
at but um at the that um influenced the
genre but a film uh just a film watching
experience in and of itself
um wake me when it's over kiddo what
about Woody Allen oh uh what about Woody
Allen uh he um is the least challenged
of these directors he's the most
narcissistic he he's not the other
actors in his films are not
well-directed he is um just driving
himself it's just kind of um a
masturbatory exercise and I'll tell you
what about what like I don't want to
bring up um anything too unsavory but he
made a pretty unsavory film in Manhattan
he's dating a high school girl and I
think that I just like that that is
um I don't know that's pretty off that's
offputting to me and again I don't want
to go down the rabbit hole on uh that uh
what Whatchamacallit but um yeah I feel
like uh Woody Allen he's a good comedy
director he's also a little bit one note
like did he direct anything else has he
directed in that decade in that decade
his more serious stuff like Hannah and
her sisters and crimes and misdemeanors
um didn't come until the 80s right but
Annie Hall was had dramatic elements
Manhattan certainly had dramatic
elements even a movie like Interiors
which suffered from I think people
expect in Annie Hall again and the fact
that it didn't it was very dramatic I
think that he did show range I think
that you could ask best actress winner
Diane Keaton she was well directed in
Annie Hall I think that I would say that
most of them were and I think that he
was I he did not if anything just his
very nature he seated the the good parts
to his co-stars just because he he
didn't feel comfortable being the center
of attention he was always the didn't
feel comfortable but I'm saying he was
always the nebish he was always the guy
that's all he can do yeah yeah you play
that hand you're deal but he was giving
like he was the stupid guy he was giving
he would give the you know the smart
stuff to his co-stars he was the guy
that you were laughing at and his
co-stars were the smart on so I think
that oh so he wanted to get the laughs
no I'm just saying I'm saying that the
fact that he was in all his movies that
doesn't mean that he sucked all the
oxygen out of it he gave his coars a lot
uh scorsi I think he I love watching
people this is a SC
scorsi I think he did a lot of great
work with diro in the 7s mean streets
and Taxi Driver those were certainly
those were both I think kind of loner
crime movies uh I think that he was a
little bit more New York New York I'm
not so sure about in the middle of all
that I think that the 80s a lot of is
where he found a lot of his artistic
Merit and taxi drivers a great film but
I think that Woody Allen has more great
films just in that particular decade
same with Spielberg he certainly Jaws
revolutionized the business model of
movie M and that movie by itself if we
were going like one movie to one movie
that would be a fight but I think just
against the filmographies of Allan and
soresi I think you're right the 80s were
Spielberg's Forte he did make two very
good movies but I just don't think that
two is enough to be considered in the
same league as these what do you think
about these choices I think it's a
question of Versatility and I think
Spielberg even in just a few movies
showed more versatility than a full
decade of Woody Allen or a full decade
of Martin Chi who really while making
fantastic films if you compare them to
someone like Robert Alman who was making
way different kinds of movies every time
and I think Spielberg just with a couple
of movies already showed that he was on
to something amazing um I would like to
say that um not only did uh Martin
scorsi make uh the best films that um
stylistically told an exciting story his
camera work that he introduced um the
visually the way the camera moved in
Mean Streets that affected a generation
so um okay let's so let's shift gears
and talk about just the film making here
the way scor scor's eye the way scorsi
shot New York City man I mean Woody
Allen like two New York directors I'll
take scors sei's vibrant City over Woody
Allen's um I don't know I think scori
makes the city more of a of a character
with a p and a heartbeat there's an
energy on the East Coast you know it if
you've been there scorsi makes it
crackle um and it's in his camera all
three of these directors were Innovative
scores was definitely Innovative a lot
of camera work Spielberg obviously very
Innovative in his use for special
effects I think that Woody Allen was
Innovative in the way that he shot and
did comedy the split screens in any Hall
he would use subtitles he would do he
would do flashback absurdity stuff that
I mean I think that's you hadn't seen in
a mainstream comedy like that and he
kind of brought it back he modernized
the kind of screw ball comedy I think of
the' 40s modernized it brought into the
70s which is a style that I I think had
been missing and that's why they stand
out so much so again I think it's these
are three great filmmakers and if you
have to make a decision you have to just
look at how singular they are and I
think Woody Allen films are the most
singular because they're personal
because one more point I mean um also
look at the family tree look at the
people who he's influenced you wouldn't
have had that slow-mo in Reservoir Dogs
without scorei you wouldn't have had
Paul Thomas Anderson's um shots in
Boogie Nights and so much that is
influenced his career and stylistic uh
uh usage of the camera um without scorsi
so um for the working with actors for
the um the different uh textures of his
films um thank you for bringing up new
New York New York that was a wonderful
chance he took and it's it's an amazing
uh uh film with Liza Manelli and uh it's
just fun um yeah he's definitive the
best director last thought day I would
say only one of these three guys scared
the whole world out of the ocean and I
think only one of these three guys
created the summer blockbuster and
that's Steven spiber hey all right I
love saying Dan aru against his favorite
favorite director of all time my
favorite movie of all time was great
that's happens in the flying fight Lon
uh not a lot of facts to check amazingly
you guys all got 100% on your movies
linking up to the decade nobody went
outside the decade you guys oh I forgot
to mention the Departed
1979 there was there was some push back
back online from how's comment about
Mean Streets inventing the street tough
genre obviously there were a lot of
crime Street tough movies before that um
also close encounters totally holds up
uh and then other filmmakers that people
mentioned a lot George Lucas Sydney LT
Vera Herzog Richard Donner Mel Brooks
Brian dealma Sam penpa and Bob FY popped
up yeah great Alin did not come up
online but in my heart in my heart Alin
was in the Hat Alman was in the Hat
I yeah fre banovich was there so Adam
are you having fun before I no I'm a
huge Spielberg fan so it was really hard
to kind of not just jump straight on
Spielberg but Dan I thought almost had
him with the he did only have two great
movies but they were the two greatest
movies so I was a little bit on Dave
yeah thank you I knew I liked
you well it's time time for me to
terminate with extreme prejudice or pick
the winner and I was exactly the same as
you Adam your last Point Dave really got
me over the line the fact that he
created the summer blockbuster those
films that he did and he showed range at
the same time so Dan gets the point I
mean Dave gets
the Dave gets the point Sorry do nothing
to the conspiracy theorist in the com
section it don't it was just me going
crazy
again the internet has your back 45%
pick Spielberg 42% for sces 13% for
Woody Allen so close so close that means
Dave and Dan both have a point Hal
you've still got plenty of chances to go
right what's that uh that it's a is it a
book and a documentary uh Mavericks and
about the 70s easy
writers such a great book yeah I love it
and I like Rebels and the Backlot about
the '90s directors as well and I love
this show cuz we get to talk about Stu
all right let's get into question three
which is which classic film star would
you want to see in a present day violent
gritty R rated movie and Dan you are up
first I went with an actor who I think
just missed out on the chance to do this
and that is Lee Marvin uh Lee Marvin was
in real life what you would call a tough
some [__] uh he was uh injured in World
War II great shot of Lee Marvin he was
injured in World War II won the Purple
Heart came back for fun he used to fish
for great white sharks in Australia as a
matter of fact he turned down the role
of quent because he thought that him
fighting against the great white shark
would make him look less cool uh so this
was a guy who he had the goods in real
life and he was in movies like The Dirty
Dozen he was in movies like a point
blank where which are you know cool
badass movies but that were just before
movies were able to embrace really
getting to the nitty-gritty he was he
was up for uh uh s Pampa and the Wild
Bunch he ended up not doing that movie
he did some supporting roles in action
movies later in his career in the 80s
but he never got the chance to be in one
of those real tough and gritty action
movies and I feel like he would be so
great in one of those movies point blank
is a movie that was remade uh with Mel
Gibson as payback um in the '90s and was
such a great update to that story it
really went to places where I think that
point Blake wasn't able to go and if
he'd been able to do that I think that
he would have been such a badass and so
I think this is a guy who you know
sometimes you see actors that just kind
of missed their window to maybe do some
work that really would have taking them
to the next level I think Lee Marvin is
one of those guys and I would love to
have seen him get a just a little bit
longer to do just a great big bloody
action movie yeah all these guys are so
cool Dave your choice I mean how can
there be any other answer to this
question than Steve McQueen the absolute
coolest movie star look at look at him
the coolest movie star of all time and
first of all he's been in so many iconic
movies like The Great Escape and papon
where he really showed some great acting
chops and bullet and he even had an
Oscar nomination for best actor for the
Sand Pebbles but to Dan's point this is
a man whose life was cut short he died
at only 50 years old and I'm not a
humongous fan of gritt violent R-rated
you know crazy ultraviolent movies but I
think someone like Steve McQueen could
bring so much to that genre much in the
way that someone like Liam niss has done
I think I think in many ways Stephen
Queen is kind of a forefather of a great
cool actor like Liam NES today and uh I
think Stephen McQueen would have looked
fantastic throughout his 50s and his 60s
into his early 70s much like Harrison
Ford does and I would have loved to have
seen him make so many more movies
including a movie like the ones we're
talking about I would love to see olda
Steve McQueen how um I'm uh picking Kirk
Douglas and he 100 years old so crazy
amazing yeah oh man look at that chin
look at that guy God damn it that's a
man's chin right
there oh yeah oh what the so um and the
main reason uh I I was back and forth
between uh Kirk Doug and Jimmy Kagney
and it's because it came down to those
two for me um for one reason uh they
came before Marlon Brando came to
Hollywood and James Dean came to
Hollywood and um Turned acting on its
ear and brought realism from the new
school in New York City to acting in
Hollywood the actors that you brought up
were uh were both um after that and I
feel like they had that realism we have
not seen that realism from Kirk Douglas
he was very
stylized in his acting if you go back
and watch it so much of it is stylized
in the way that this Mid-Atlantic accent
is stylized he was stylized drama these
uh yeah I'm starting but already but
yeah um yeah he so it would be the most
satisfying
to see him navigate those Waters of a
gritty R movie where uh I hope you can
bleep this the sensors are going to have
our butts but where [__] hits the fan
you know what I mean okay he never got
to do that with real acting uh with the
real acting chops that Brando James Dean
changed acting forever all right open
for him I think that's cuz that was kind
of outside of Kirk Douglas's style like
he was kind of from the Char H School of
like I am a Prestige actor like he it's
not like he was forced into those roles
I think he liked doing those roles and
he was in uh Paths of Glory and he did
some kind of war movies and stuff and so
but I I think that he just kind of liked
doing those kind of Spartacus roles a
little bit more I think both of our
choices Steve McQueen and Lee Marvin
really like to get kind of into those
nitty-gritty tough guy roles um I think
the big difference though between Lee
Marvin and Steve McQueen is like this is
what actor would you want to see in one
of these movies and I think Steve
McQueen is so cool I mean Great Escape
and jumping over the razor wire with the
bike and like I don't know how much
cooler Steve McQueen could get than the
Steve McQueen that we got like he was Mr
cool and the reason that I picked Lee
Marvin wasn't so much it was because we
didn't get to see I think there were
sides of Lee Marvin that we didn't get
to see whereas Steve McQueen I think
could be in one of those movies but he'd
be the Steve McQueen that we know and
love and the reason that I picked Lee
Marvin was that I think that there is a
side to him that was restrained a little
bit he would have taken these roles but
I think there's a side that was pulled
back a little bit because of the times
that he operated I would say it was um
Le Lee Marvin is a hair away from from
being in the gritty films we're talking
about um the dirty doesen there are raw
moments in that movie and the acting
style is real and gritty the suspense is
intense when they're trying to break
into the Nazi stronghold there uh like
stuff is hitting the fan and Steve
McQueen it's very real gritty acting in
a movie like bullet where you have the
most intense car chase ever set to film
that's a gritty moment Kirk Douglas was
not given the opportunity because he was
groomed in a different period of actors
he absolutely could have handled that
role a movie that you love big carnival
he like imagine playing that character
with that much more level of just real
truth to it or young young man with a
horn where he played this um jazz
musician up and cominging in New York
City going through trials and
tribulations um if he was able to be in
that gritty level of truth that we're
talking about here that it would be
unbelievable to see we've never see
anything like it you're these actors I
feel like we have but he played that
role in a in the whole slth big car had
two different names so brilliantly
because that was his style and because
he brought so much of that Kirk Douglas
attitude towards it and I think that he
just kind of operated in a different
Arena um that doesn't maybe lend itself
to that grittiness I think that Lee
Marvin again just through personal
experience is a guy who had seen that
kind of thing firsthand not that these
other guys haven't but just through his
life experience and didn't get I feel
like it's just something that he would
have wanted to do and just could been in
gritty
movies but they but again they were
constrained at the time they could not
go all the way
with about movies that are 40 years old
I we want to see these guys in a
contemporary gritty
rated movie those are very different
even from bullet although your point is
well taken Kirk Douglas I feel like
because we've seen Michael Douglas in
movies like falling down in some other
kind of violent movies I feel like we've
had our moment with the Douglas family
in this type of
film and Lee Marvin's great but just
he's just outranked in every way most of
all easy cool by Steve McQueen there's
just nobody who who presents that and I
think that Stephen Queen would have
really risen to the occasion of being in
a role that requires the physicality of
the type of movie We're talk what kind
of movie would you love to see each of
your choices in Steve McQueen in Taken
taken what kind of movie um how
about Kirk Douglas stranded in outer
space having to murder aliens in life
yeah oh in Aliens oh in in aliens in
Aliens in the derivative one of life
or and Dan yeah I I think I would like
to see Lee Marvin do the kind of Western
that he missed out on with the Wild
Bunch really go back and play a kind of
Clint Eastwood esque figure like an
Unforgiven that could really you know
almost reflect on his own filmography a
little bit in his past so this would be
kind of an olderly Marvin um I I like
what eood did in that movie and I think
that would be a great opportunity for
him all right final thoughts before I
wrap it up anything to add Last Chance
um yeah I I will just again say that uh
we've we've I feel like we've seen that
style with these actors because it was a
different period in Hollywood in the 60s
there was a distinct shift um signal by
directors like Sergio Leone Sam peek and
paaw to the realism um that you could uh
portray violence with in film um and uh
these actors were post that era this
actor I'm talking about was pre that era
it was be the most satisfying uh to see
Kirk Douglas shift gears and find that
level of realism I think Kirk Douglas
was working well into many of the mean
you know he's only been out of the game
since I think the '90s so I think he had
more of a chance like tough guys he had
more of a chance to operate inside of
the genre uh afterwards that I don't
think that Lee Marvin and Steve McQueen
necessarily had so I think that for me
it's really just more of um a missed
opportunity things flavors that I would
like to see I think that Kirk Douglas
just is on a different volume from what
we're talking about and I think Steve
McQueen again I don't know what more I
could see from Steve McQueen in one of
these movies versus uh what I think with
Lee Marvin is is is another side of that
actor that I and I would just say of all
three of these guys the one who least
scratched the surface of what he's
capable of doing with Steve McQueen and
he would have excelled in this type of
movie tough as always feel like I'm
anding this is tough it really really is
H Lon wow this one is really tough great
arguments all around AR to me I didn't
have any facts to check but I do have a
long list of other suggestions from the
web uh Humphrey Bogart came up the most
that was my number two so many people
really wanted to see this kind of movie
Gary Cooper came up a bunch Marlon
Brando Charlton H John Wayne Errol Flynn
Carrie Grant and what I thought was an
interesting one Sean connory cuz we did
sort of get him in like the rock so
Untouchables but yeah like people want
to see him in something even harder even
something grittier I would have gone
with May
West my second one was Betty Davis yeah
bet
Davis um and Lon would you go with based
on the arguments this was really tough I
mean um I liked what Hal was saying
about you know Kirk Douglas had this
much more classical style he didn't
really get to play these kinds of roles
and and I was thinking of you know like
Henry Fonda when he did you know Once
Upon a Time in the West like that chance
to really go against tight so I was
pretty one over there but I I think in
the end I got to go with Dave and Steve
McQueen I think he's right he just like
the essential badass cool action star
and to see him today I really do think
we would have seen a whole different
side to what the queen could do I love
that whole
sofa they are on your side um yeah this
is a hard choice I loved all your
arguments I would love to see um Kirk
Douglas in
aliens that would be awesome I'll have
that realism um and Dan you made such a
great point about point blank to
paycheck and it would have been great to
see like that's a good um sort of
analogy for something that leave Marvin
could be in um but I'm gonna go again
with the the queen of cool the McQueen
of cool with Steve McQueen and Dave all
right another
Point pay payb not paycheck little late
late fact check there go watch it but
not the direct now do we do we get to
hear the percentages on that one oh yeah
I can pull that up uh we had 59% for
Steve McQueen 29% for Kirk Douglas only
12% for Lee Marvin but again I feel like
everybody watching this should go watch
Point Blank if you guys haven't seen it
it's just cuz he's not as much of a he's
a little bit lesser known I think yeah
and I think yeah you've actually made me
now want to go explore more Lee Marvin
your your argument and the picture that
ran because he looked fantastic I want
to I want to know more everyone should
Explore More leave Marvin and I never
apologize it's a sign of weakness so
we're going to get into round four which
is which movie is the ultimate time
capsu so in other words what is the
movie best represents the time and place
Dave okay so Alicia you and I have
something in common which is that we're
both Turner Classic Movies fans and
employees and this past week was the
Turner Classic Movies film festival and
then movie that they chose as the
opening night film was In the Heat of
the Night and the reason they chose it
is because this year was the 50th
anniversary of that movie for people who
don't know there's a murder in
Mississippi uh Sydney poer who is a
police officer from Philadelphia who
happens to be in
town gets arrested because he is
suspected to be the murderer and he kind
of teams up with this racist local cop
played by Rod stiger who won the Oscar
for best actor for that movie and the
two of them kind of help solve this uh
murder together and it is unbelievable
how In the Heat of the Night is a
complete and perfect snapshot of that
time time in the mid to late 60s
particularly in the South where there
were so many racial tensions and so much
mistrust and so much uh so many horrible
things going on in that region to the
point where when they made the movie
Sydney po refused to even film it south
of the Mason Dixon line they had to find
a town in Illinois in Southern Illinois
to double for Mississippi because he did
not want to film because he had had
issues when he and Harry bellante had
traveled in the South so this film is so
vivid it's so power powerful it's a
great murder mystery but it also is a
great snapshot of a moment in time in
race relations and sadly even though it
feels like it is relevant to 1967 it is
just as relevant 50 years later in 2017
so it's almost a time capsule of now and
then which gives it double power in my
mind how um I'm going full Scott Mance
on this
one and I'm choosing you going to stand
on your chair citizen cane it's the
Citizen Cane of time
capsules um
so in choosing this movie and thinking
about this question um I wanted uh to
pick a film that really
transcends um simply uh okay um giving
us a snapshot because I feel like there
are countless movies that do that this
movie defines a people
an era a century um the the minds of
Americans
uh there's no film like this that you
could watch and really get a sense of a
period in time in such vibrant different
ways in so many different Industries in
so many different facets of people
government
entertainment um it's fascinating in
what it covers and captures and for that
reason alone for it being such a
definitive story of the early DEC the
late 1800s to the um early 1900s mid uh
to early UHS 20s 30s um it's the best
time capsule I I'd show it to aliens I'd
show it to aliens to let them know hey
this is what um this
time period was like all right Dan uh I
went with a movie that I think is is
almost an embodiment of the moment and
the time that it was made in which is
Easy Rider we mentioned Easy Rider
Raging Bulls this is a movie that a lot
of people credit with you know being one
of the things that kickstarted new
Hollywood and the the Resurgence of
independent film making this was Dennis
Hopper going crazy and making a movie
that you had was a five hours long and I
think what it is is it's not just that
it takes place in the 60s I think that
it is so of its time that it shows you
that era the good parts and of course
you the hippies and the free love and
that that hope that they embodied comes
through in that film but I think it also
shows the excesses I think it shows the
pitfalls of that time and of that
lifestyle and I think that movie has
those flaws in it the Indulgence the
excess of of really getting into that
counterculture and going too far with it
and I think it also shows in a weird
way it captured for me and I wasn't
there in the' 60s obviously it was a
little before my time but I think the
movie itself almost shows you what it
felt like to them to be part of that
counterculture because it shows you the
dark side of it without going too far
into spoilers the ending of the movie
kind of embodies the what happens when
you upset the societal Norms what
happens when you are the new thing
around and people don't understand you
and they don't get what's going on and
the fear and the bigotry and the
Prejudice that comes with that I think
that Easy Rider I is such a you just
watch that movie and you can see not
just what the movie feels but what the
filmmakers were going through what their
life was like and while it's not a
perfect film it is far from a perfect
film I think that it is such a snapshot
of Just A Slice of Life of that precise
time unlike any other film it's not a
recreation of its time it is its time
and I think that's what you're looking
for for in a time capsule all incredible
Classics so uh let's argue against them
listen Citizen Kane's an amazing movie I
I just don't think it's the perfect
choice for this particular question only
because I do think it it's more
representative of a a few decades as
opposed to a moment in time although I
totally get what you're saying about not
wanting to go too literal on the
snapshot idea it's interesting that Dan
you and I both chose 60s movies but I
would argue that In the Heat of the
Night is more representative of the time
because in my opinion race relations
Civil Rights was the defining issue of
the 1960s more than hippie culture was
so I think that in the he the night is
more representative of that time and
just the fact that as I said they
couldn't even shoot the movie where it
takes place because of the issues
represented in the movie shows you how
timely and and how representative of
that time frame the movie was um I I
would say like the span of of One Life
can be a time capsule I mean um we talk
about like there's so many different
eras there um you know there are
medieval films there are films that uh
you know that uh take place um during
the prehistoric eras uh just because
it's a little bit longer of a time I
don't think disqualifies it I feel like
uh I mean these choices wonderful films
cancel each other out uh they're um
because like why is your film better
than say best years of our lives uh one
of the most wonderful groundbreaking uh
um stories of soldiers coming home after
World War II showing varying stories and
why is yours better than his I don't see
it as far as the um being a definitive
Time Capsule this man's life was a time
capsule open up that closet and walk
through it it's a literal I mean his
storage uh room um uh Citizen Cane I
mean it is like man I I chose freaking
Citizen Kane full scotman but I feel
like it and it is um very much uh hisory
uh be aware of history or were doomed to
repeat it that Cult of Personality that
is um Charles Foster Kane echoing
William Randolph Hurst and today we have
a powerful personality in charge of the
country who uh man if you look at his
story you can make a cane likee film
about him well I think that you are I C
Kane again it's a great pick but I I
agree Dave it's not for this category I
think the Citizen Cane is you know I
think for something to be a time capsule
it has to be of its time Citizen Cane
was a recreation of times earlier from
that movie you're right it went all the
way to the 1800s and the early the 1900s
the 1920s I don't think that it is a
time capsule movie I think that it looks
back and I think that In the Heat of the
Night is a relatable movie it certainly
has themes but In the Heat of the Night
I think is a movie that could be made
today and still be as relevant I mean
these are these are problems that we are
still very much facing in today's
society and I think that that's a movie
that resonates because it has a lot of
themes that we can relate to today still
have hipsters today we still have bikers
but not hippies like these guys again
like I think when you look at a time
capsule when people open up a time
capsule they pull these things out and
they'll go like oh I remember that
they'll shake their head at some of it
they'll they'll you know like oh what
was I thinking at some of it and I think
that that's for me what what makes easy
writer the best choice in this category
because some of it isn't as relatable
and you look at it and you go like
that's what that was like like oh wow
like they went there they did that with
this this film making choice or like
that is a weird interesting way to do to
approach the acting on that or the
editing or something like I think that
it is so representative of when it was
made and I don't think you could make
that movie the same way in that same
tone at any other time than the exact
time that it was made and H I want to
hear why you chose to isn't Kane for the
Time Capture if it's a period film like
Dan say um because uh I I feel like the
the Time Capsule it's of spans the early
1900s I feel like that is the snapshot
we see industry Hollywood um government
there's it shows what made those major
forces in everyday life tick I think is
very much um or Orson Wells uh took um
an a complete picture of the world I
mean trying to you know Jam all those
things in the same way like Robert
Altman might try to um convey the
complexity of conversations and social
interactions with his ver style this
takes that macro look at the world
America the power structure at that
moment and I would say you know um again
it's that that film's a good snapshot
but at the same time this movie was made
we were going to the moon the Mets won
the World Series there's so much more
going on and here like uh at the time
that was made uh you know Vietnam was
happening and there's so much that it
doesn't show about life uh so yeah for
those reasons all righty long uh again
not a lot of facts to check as the
fighters picked up J Kane released in
1941 but set throughout the early uh
Century uh lots of suggestions from
Twitter Saturday Night Fever To Kill a
Mocking Bird Harvey Rebel Without a
Cause American Graffiti Dog Day
Afternoon and A Hard Day's Night all I
thought good suggestion
great choices I mean especially in the'
60s and 70s I feel like they were filmed
you know like you guys were saying that
makes you feel like you were part of the
time yeah Adam are you having fun still
lost you I continue to catch love I I'm
still within the Heat of the Night like
that was the same you could open it now
and be shocked you could open it in 50
years and hope you're not shocked and it
gets better but I I was I was all there
I had American Graffiti is mine so
that's your choice yeah good choice good
Choice well um yeah I've got to I've got
to choose against three Incredible
movies but for the reasons that he said
about it being only made at its time and
not repeated again Dan gets the points
that was a great
great soon as you said that I thought
he's got it yeah unfortunately saying in
the he night again it is true what Dan
said about it that it's like it could be
made today yeah again watch all of these
movies we mentioned this movie unless we
make reference to some current
Transformers movie or something watch
all the movies that we mentioned all all
right we're up to round five and this
one is what classic film genre should
make a comeback how um well I'm going to
go with slapstick comedy
um we uh we live in interesting times
and uh I feel feel like what the world
needs a little bit more of is uh that
the dynamic that you uh had with uh
heurn and Tracy uh uh
um uh Clark Gable and Claud coar um
these we do not see in the current
romantic comedies and um the current
crop of relationship uh inspired based
films the kind of sparkling dynamics
that were present
in these crazy uh films like bringing up
baby um just these the
circumstances and the emotions and the
uh comedy of manners and the sexual
tension that existed and that they that
dance through these films is like
nothing we have nowadays I feel like uh
um uh sex and romantic comedies have
gotten like either dumb or blunt you
know you don't there's no more
appreciation for the sparkling dialogue
and the and the Dynamics that um these
films distinctly had and you don't have
to go as as stylized as this really no
that's what I'm saying uh you to do Jen
Jason Lee and HUD sucker proxy you could
you could do it with um with well
written um uh tonally uh shifted films
that um I mean I mean check out like uh
I I feel like TV does it that much more
like you'll find um these fun
interesting Dynamics in on TV shows like
you're the worst or something like that
that's like oh wow that is sharp and
real but it's yet to translate to the
big screen nearly as much so um yeah for
that reason alone I will say oh good
time SL comedies D I miss the hardboiled
Philip Marlo type detective movie I feel
like now you know for a while that was
kind of when film the war came in that
was kind of the thing was the 40s you
have the voice over you have and then I
feel like over time it got parody so
much and things like Naked Gun the Naked
Gun movies and just it happens when
something catches on of course people
are going to start and then I feel like
people stop taking it seriously and I
feel like almost like it's
Mysteries it's rare now to see a movie
that is just a straight up mystery movie
like just like put the pieces together
like it's a it's a it's like Gone Girl
it's like it's a mystery but it's also a
sexual thriller or it's like you know
it's a it's a mystery but it's a comedy
and I missed that time when when they
took that seriously and you would get
the kind of hardboiled leading man or
Leading Lady and have the voice over and
just a just a good oldfashioned mystery
I think that's why when movies like
usual suspects come out nowadays that
kind of do that and do it well people
are like wow that wow that was such a
great movie it's because and I think the
reason people don't make it is cuz it's
difficult to do it's difficult to fool
an audience now because they're going in
trying to put the pieces together I miss
well done like detective movies where
it's just it's you and the detective
you're on the same team he's talking to
you the whole movie and you're trying to
figure this thing out and they're hard
to make I think that's why people don't
make them very much anymore and I would
love to see them come back and see a
Resurgence in that genre all right Dave
well you know back in the day there was
this kind of unfortunately titled genre
of films called the women's picture and
it you know what it meant was it was a
film that basically was appealing to a
female audience because it had a woman
or women in the lead role and you know
there was this massive tradition of
incredible films like the women which
was 120 speaking roles all of which were
female all of the men were only talked
about they were never there was not one
man actually seen in that George cuor
film of course and then when I hosted on
TCM last summer it was Olivia deavin
month because she was turning 100 and I
got to introduce all of these phenomenal
Olia de havin movies like The ays into
each's own all these phenomenal films
where she was running the show and then
there's the whole bunch of Katherine
Hein movies like Alice Adams when she
was younger films like that that
showcase women in all of their
complexity in a way that is shocking
when you realize they're from the 30s
40s and 50s um that filmmakers seem to
look at women as more complex entities
than they seem to today where women are
only the girlfriend the wife the I candy
the secretary or the maid and and I
would love to see a return to that and
for proof of how well it would be
received these days I think we can only
look towards what is the one piece of
entertainment that I think most people
have talked about in 2017 it's big
little lies and that is because that
cast of Nicole Kidman and REE
Witherspoon and Zoe krabit and shayen
Woodley and Laura
dur they anchored that with such
fascinating performances because they
were given the opportunity to show
complexity on screen and I think it's
sad that they have to go to cable TV now
to to find anything that lets them do
something that measures up to the
women's pictures of 60 years ago so I
think it'd be great if we could bring
those back all genres I want to see back
so open for him H Dan I it's tough
because I I you know in a perfect world
we would have all of these yeah um I
think with the women's picture I I agree
100% like that I I think that's more
like I don't want to see that genre come
back I just want to see that hap happen
in general
Beyond just a genre of pictures like it
would just be great if those projects
would get greenlighted I think we're
taking steps way too slowly but I think
we're taking steps toward that but more
than just bringing that genre back I
just want that to be an industrywide
thing of of just looking at female Le
properties and saying like they are just
as uh bankable and and we're going to
put as much support behind them as
anything else so yeah and I think uh you
know part of that comes with you know uh
Hollywood uh just being a little bit
more open and amendable when it comes to
you know casting like you know uh like
just the age disparities are ridiculous
and the rules for men and the rules for
women it's uh all you know it's it's
some real BS uh but um I mean I
feel uh just women uh Le pictures
pictures that are uh more um inclusive
of people uh of color um and uh just all
different stories need to be told but
told but I I feel like um there are
still we there are uh wonderful uh
female Le pictures I mean uh Carol Blue
Jasmine anything else Kate Blanchette
touches um but
um I feel like we have them though I
feel like we don't have this Dynamic uh
of these slapstick comedies um anymore
and that's something that we haven't
seen and you you even named some recent
uh you know hardboiled uh detectives I
feel like this is there's um a a dir
that uh needs to be uh replenished here
I would say there is I would say yes
there are female Le films but they're
always this big Carol Room Brooklyn like
I back in the day when the women's
pictures were big those were the big
movies that the studios were putting out
they weren't these little Indie movies
that only the Oscar voters saw and the
people who watched this show um so I I
think the danger of slapstick is that
you can get into kind of farly Brothers
territory or Adam Sandler territory
which I think is God forid right but if
we could have the Smart Ones back that
would be great too yeah that's yeah but
I but I think if of the three I think
the women's picture is the one that is
the most invisible right now I mean but
I think that for example the two new
Star Wars franchises the Rogue one and
then Force awakens and Slash the new
Trilogy the the face of those franchises
are both women and I think you are
seeing Resurgence I think you are seeing
not even I don't want to say Resurgence
I think you're seeing things start to
equal out and I think you're seeing
there an adjustment so I would say that
there are steps being taken towards
bringing I don't mean women back no not
sci-fi ships and and issues that affect
women not just women with a gun in their
hand okay so yeah I I I don't know it's
it's hard for me to draw the line
between what's a women's picture and
what is just equality and fairness and
entertainment um screw ball comedy um I
I I don't know I would just I think that
we have comedy I think that the screw
ball comedy has a certain Cadence and a
Tempo that registered to audiences that
were raised on Vaudeville and were
raised on that kind of Rhythm that maybe
wouldn't work as well now I think that a
lot of times they're almost too fast
like even for me it's hard to like whoaa
back up back up back up you know I think
that people there it's been mixed into a
lot of genres of Comedy into what we
have in modern day comedy um I don't
know if just throwing it all the way
back to the way that they used to do it
would connect with everybody necessarily
because it is a Tempo thing and it's not
a Tempo that most people's ears are
attuned to it is a I mean it's uh one of
the uh something that I would compare
that Tempo to it in a modern sense might
be vep uh vep moves at a pace that might
be too fast for um I it's the I for me
it's the most jokes per capita on
television and the best dialogue um of
any comedy on television uh my opinion
so to capture something that has that
level of intelligence yeah God forbid
Adam Sandler um and um and what about
detective maybe I need to hear some
arguments against that yeah I I feel
like um we've we've modernized it and we
have like uh you know a version of what
you're talking about and like usual
suspects but also I feel like there's a
version of that in di hard there's a
version of that in uh Lethal Weapon um
the the uh Bruce Willis and the Mel
Gibson characters from those movies I
feel uh very much uh touch that genre I
I I mean that to me is very much more
action it's not that kind of
inclusiveness as far as like you're
watching but you're not what I love is
the idea of with the detective you're
trying to solve this mystery um you know
I think there are movies that are like
it but I don't think that they I think
that genre by and large has kind of Gone
by the wayside and I think that's a
shame and and I you know I I think
really all three of our problems with
all three of us is that they've dumbed
down all three of these genres I think
that they have really minimized or
dumbed down where where these came from
and I just think mine happens to have
been dumbed down the most but uh yeah
okay Dave final thoughts anything about
I I would say we have I hear your point
about the the hard boil film but I think
we have crime everywhere in in movies
and I think we have lots of Comedy if
there's one genre that can really
revolutionize the movie industry and
change it the most and allow 50% of
working actors the female ones to
actually have something to do rather
than play the girlfriend I think the
women's picture would make the biggest
difference okay Lon I forgot to do the
poll I'm sorry last last poll so I
apologize that no problem uh a lot of
this this one brought a lot of
discussion about what sort of defines
these genres that was what was going on
so like a lot of discussion about is
slapstick comedy screw ball comedy are
we combining those two or we considering
them separately uh same with Detective
movie are those noirs or are we talking
specifically about detective movie and
then same with the women's picture are
those just movies with a central female
character or are they about certain
kinds of topics so is Ghostbusters a
women's picture lot lots of discussion
on those uh a lot of people also took
issue with dance point about their not
being good Mysteries but when they would
name them just as Dan was arguing
they're kind of all overlaps with other
genres so like who frame Roger Rabbit
came up seven came up Usual Suspects but
not maybe exactly the same kind of hard
voil uh mystery we talk about other
genres people mention historical epics
Coming of Age dramas and westerns
westerns came up
aan was a
western definitely um this is a this is
a difficult Choice um they're all really
good good
um L I'm going to go to you to help me
out with this one uh ge I mean these are
these were all great choices uh I would
I would go with really any one of these
but I know uh I think everybody made
such a good argument that I'm going to
just go back to my own personal
preference which be hardboiled detective
movies so I go Dan well I mean they all
made such great points I I didn't hear
that much against detective movie and I
think you're right that they don't have
the both the film Noah but there is a
detective style as well that over
overarch everything so I'm going to go
with Dan so that means Dan has three
sorry H oh it's okay it happens
sometimes take the goose
egg I do have a yes thank you I always
forget that 53% went with hard boil
detective movies 32% went with slapstick
comedy only 15% for women's must be a
lot of guys watching this show I feel
like there might be it's also a it it
does sound confusing but it was
definitely a genre where women would be
seen doing amazing things and the funny
thing was about the women's picture was
that it always had to have the message
at the end that the women should choose
love or a man over their choice so but
they were actually empowering to women
at the time because they would show
women like being airplane pilots and you
know saving a baby by using a hair pin
you know from choking and doing these
crazy things and at the end they're like
oh but I just going to go with this guy
for
this interesting um but no that's didn't
fact into it because I love those movies
and his girl Friday is the reason why I
wanted to be a reporter and I don't
remember that she goes with the guy at
the end I remember her being a badass
and if you like classic movies and the
dynamic of just women in Hollywood I
cannot recommend enough Feud which is on
FX right now Betty Davis Joan Crawford
so much about chair exactly and so much
about how just they were uh exploited uh
to play into that Narrative of what
people expected of them and I'm I'm
we're addicted to it and every week so
can't wait to finish it cuz and it's uh
quick aside I know we're going to keep
moving but um it's funny that it during
the studio system actually offered women
more interesting roles than now because
they each had defined personas so Betty
Davis would always get her Betty Davis
pictures and Joan Crawford knew what she
was going to play Ol had have learned
the same now it's like no no defined
personalities like there was anyway we
are on to the speed round so that means
it is Dan versus Dave and oh my gosh
how I condemn you to living death
and to help me out with this speed round
because life moves pretty fast and so
does the speed round so I'll explain
this for Dave he hasn't been on before
this is a chance to earn five more
points and win the game the panelist
with the lowest points is automatically
out or the first to get to the highest
wins um it's a don't remind me it's a qu
we hand out the question you got to
answer quickly whoever answers first
gets to debate bait first you each get
20 seconds to say your choice and then
5sec rub bottle at the end and either or
question if you both choose the same
answer then it's the one who answered
first who gets to do it got it we should
do a it's a 10c Rob 10 10 would be
really quick yeah used to be five back
in the day way too way too short all
right so let's get into it are you guys
ready yes let's do this
okay what classic film star's life would
make the best
biopic o Montgomery Cliff mhm oh do I
now say why no um Grace
Kelly all right Montgomery Cliff Grace
Kelly Dave you're first well montg Clift
was first of all one of the most
charismatic and popular movie stars of
his day but he had so many dramatic
things that went on in his life first of
all he was hiding his homosexuality so
that was very hard for him plus halfway
through his career he had this really
frightening automobile accident which
completely mangled his face and he had
to completely change his career all
right d I think that the Grace Kelly's
story is interesting because it's kind
of it's kind of an an anomaly and
something you don't see anymore which is
somebody who's like the number one star
completely gives it up for love and I
think that's such a Hollywood like that
feels like a Hollywood Story that feels
like something that that would be
written and written I don't know why I
said it like that but the idea of like
giving that up for love and and becoming
the princess you know all right 10
seconds no one had to go through the
adversity that Montgomery Clift had to
go through Grace Kelly beautiful life
princess Charmed Life and died too young
but Mont Army Cliff the drama is
unparalleled for me it's really just the
perspective that I don't get which is
like what was it that drove her to do
that because that does seem like such a
sacrifice and I see must be a great love
story for her to have given all of that
up to do what she
did how what do you think it's tough
both great choices I'd see both those
movies uh but um at the end of the day
um I feel like um I got um uh one more
reason from Dave and I feel like Dan
repeated his uh argument in the rebuttal
and also I've been told I look like a
young
salminio so uh um one of his uh one of
myum um co-stars so yeah Dave yeah I
agree I had more of a robot from Dave
that I did from Dan so Dave gets a point
that mean it is three all all right
getting exciting all right now now what
happens keep going keep going four more
questions yeah four more questions okay
so here we go get ready this is a either
all question so answer first gets the
gets to take that choice and it's very
topical Betty Davis or Joan cord from
Crawford uh Davis there we go all right
Dan you go first
I feel like Betty Davis was an iconic
clast I feel like Betty Davis struggled
to break out of it and she was the Merl
stre of her time I feel like she kind of
Rose above a little bit of that
pettiness that Joan Crawford had the
Oscar thing was pretty low for somebody
and I feel like that she did more to
kind of advocate for the independence
and for stepping out of that system than
Joan Crawford who I think was just
desperate to get back into that system
all right when you talk about actresses
of that time it's about one thing and
one thing only it's about being a diva
it's about being remembered yes Joan
Crawford only has one Oscar whereas
Betty Davis has two but Joan Crawford is
the one who has stood the test of time
and remained the biggest green Diva of
all time okay rebuttle I think that Joan
Crawford is remembered for being a diva
I think that Betty Davis is remembered
for being a great actress and if given
the two if which one I would prefer I
would prefer the person that's
remembered for for her body of work for
her career for her talent for her
skill I agree that Betty Davis was very
skilled but Joan Crawford is the one who
transcended her acting ability and
became an icon just for her entire being
not just her ability movie star versus
the actress Hal Dan sold me yeah uh I
mean just uh like I I feel like he hit
more points here and um his uh were more
persuasive all right well nobody needs
to drag each other by the floor by the
head we're going to give it to Dan I
think that's right so that means Dave
has three Dan has four we're on to the
next question ready this is this one
that I think you both will love best
movie directed by Billy Wilder
oh there some need to choose from with
Sunset
Boulevard Sunset
buou oh man which one do I want I'm
going to go with the
apartment all right let's do it so the
great thing about classic films are the
classic films that explore Hollywood
itself like All About Eve and just and
explore the entertainment world and no
movie did it better than Sunset
Boulevard and it's because of Billy
Wilder and the way that he directed it
in all of the classic lines it is
absolutely one of the most classic films
about Hollywood ever
made it is a classic film about
Hollywood but I think that the apartment
is a classic film about love and about
rejection and about pain and about uh
finding your place in the world I think
it's got broader themes than Sunset
Boulevard does I think it's more
relatable than Boulevard I think it's
more Charming than Sunset Boulevard it's
got comedy it's got deep dark drama it's
able to defly balance the two and Sunset
Boulevard is a very witty movie but I
right I think when you're thinking about
classic films you have to think about
which one has the most memorable moments
and lines and Sunset Boulevard has it
over we had faces Mr Dill my closeup
Sunset Boulevard wins out on that yeah
if you're going memorable moment Sunset
Boulevard wins but if you're looking at
the film in total I think the apartment
does so much more and plays so its hands
so much more defly than sunet vard which
is is a Noir Thriller the apartment is
just a great drama and comedy Best
Picture Winner also o Shut Up and
Deal
wow help me out man guns
blazing I feel like Dan took it for me
with a rebuttal there Lon what do you
think H this is tough and and Sunset
Boulevard is probably my personal
favorite but yeah I think Dan's last
rebuttal there was so much good stuff
crammed in there he really he really won
me over so I go Dan oh Adam yeah I'm
same Sunset Boulevard but Dan's argument
that was a pretty pretty persuasive
arguments why he's the champ let's go
with Dan so that means three to five and
we've got uh three more no two more
questions so there is a chance the best
I can do is tie the best you can do is
tie then you got a tie break all right
here we go what is the best classic
horror film ooh pre-1980 right that's
our that's our
I'm going to say Jaws jaws I'll sneak
one in right above the line and say
Halloween Halloween okay Dave Jaws we've
already discussed it on the show but it
was revolutionary and not only its film
making but its effect on the actual
business we wouldn't see the
Blockbusters that we see today without
that one movie it's a movie that changed
the way we all live the way we all
vacation and the way we all watch movies
um yeah I think maybe Define the
Blockbuster I think Halloween defined
the horror movie for the next 30 Years
Halloween is what horror movies would
later become and still are the slasher
the guy stalking the teenagers like it
was so memorable and John Carpenter
created such an atmosphere that
permeated and pervaded across the genre
that he reinvented it Halloween was
great but it's also pretty stock a a
slasher movie A Murder movie that's what
horror movies seem to always be Jaws
took it one step further by bringing it
into a compltely different world okay
argue against your FIV maybe yeah
exactly still arguing against Jaws I
think the reason that Halloween seems
stalk it's it's it's the thing people
don't remember that it was the it seems
stalk because all of the other horror
movies were trying to be Halloween
Halloween was the one that they all
emulated that Freddy and Jason emulated
[Music]
okay
hell man um
yeah at the end of the day uh um I feel
like
uh uh um Jaws is not quite uh that genre
I feel like it it it dips its toe in
those Waters um but it's also action
adventure it's um I mean I mean would
that make Jurassic Park a uh a horror
movie what you think about their their
arguments the way they argued it um I I
you know what I I I feel like uh it was
an uphill battle to climb with that
choice and I don't feel like you uh you
top yeah I mean it's a yeah I mean he is
a that that shark is a monster but this
is a definitive horror film and uh and
argued as such and uh Dan would get the
point from me well I think that although
I didn't hear any rebuttal from you
about Jaws and
what but um you you argued Halloween so
well uh saying that you know it other
movies feel like feel stock because it
created other movies and it had the
final girl and it had so much to it so
that means Dan gets another point six
points that means Dan wins
congratulations you must be oh so smart
or Oho pleasant but you're both because
you're wonderful at movie fights and uh
you know Dave I'd hate to take a a bite
out of you because you're a cookie
filled with arenic and great debating
skills you guys were very nice this was
a lot of fun thank you so much for
joining us on your first movie fights uh
where can people find you online Dave
carer on Twitter and Instagram nice how
thank you oh thanks for having me talk
about your passion which is classic I
mean you grew up with these movies yeah
um yeah my dad gave me a classic film
education growing up and uh yeah grew up
on uh you know TCM and uh AMC back when
it showed uh classic films um yeah
thanks for having me I'd uh love to uh
love to do it again sometime sweetheart
and uh well done maiden voyage here Dan
congrats and yeah um hit me up on
Twitter uhal rodnik and check out the
screen junkie show every Thursday on
YouTube awesome Dan yes so much fun to
talk classic movies with everybody and
yeah this is much much credit to Leonard
Molton who was a guest on the show and
Roger eert and uh Turner Classic Turner
Classic Movies did a lot for people
around because they I showed a lot I
remember when the AFI list came out I
watched so many of those movies on
Turner Classic Movies and if you're if
you don't watch Classic Movies go watch
them because uh it's like I've always
said they're just movies that just
happen to have been made a long time ago
they're the same as the movies that come
out now can we also remind people they
can find Alicia Malone on filmstruck
which is the streaming service by TCM
and Criterion and I'm going to be back
on TCM in the month of June hosting a
gay Hollywood movie series and we're all
members of the Amy Nicholson fan club
too by the way yes and L where can
people find you online uh they can take
it on the Arches to Twitter and find me
L nice Adam thank you so much for coming
along I hope you had fun where can
people find you uh I just Twitter
Facebook anything social media I'm just
happy to be here and 98% of the time I'm
usually agreeing with Dan on everything
he says so I'm happy I just didn't
Fanboy
out thank you really well well I'm
Alicia Malone why don't you come up
sometime and see me or you can find me
on Twitter at Lea Malone or on
filmstruck thank you so much for going
with us again for another classic film
fights it's my favorite thing to do and
we will see you soon
bye